on va se lâcher ça va être fantastique
c'est plus que
[Musique]
la note ma famille on va faire une
grosse fête là toute la famille au
Vietnam on vient les fêtes dans deux
semaines et pour bien des gens une chose
est claire la pandémie c'est terminé on
est d'origine grec
que on mange beaucoup
c'est le signe selon cette spécialiste
de la santé publique que la perception
du risque a aussi évolué chez les
experts ce qui s'est passé c'est la
vaccination qui est qui est très
largement utilisé de 1 et 2 limitations
qu'on subit les virus et qui font en
sorte que maintenant c'est très
difficile de les empêcher de circuler et
le virus il est devenu trop
fort il se transmet trop facilement il
est devenu plus fort que nous à ce
niveau là le docteur Weiss et du même
avis c'est une dynamique la maladie
infectieuse donc c'est un phénomène
dynamique c'est-à-dire qu'à un moment
donné il faut porter des masses de façon
massive extrême et intense mais à un
moment donné il faut savoir s'adapter à
une situation qui a changé et qui
échangeante par contre au quotidien
plusieurs experts préfèrent rester
prudents en répondant sur trois évite
encore les restaurants
73% porte un masque dans les transports
en commun et 60% en faisant leur
épicerie les gens s'exprimer ils ont pas
le choix d'aller faire leur marché les
parents de jeunes enfants
de un deux mois ils ont pas ils n'ont
pas le choix d'y aller il faut bien
qu'il soit là le plus qu'on va diminuer
la charge de sécrétion infectieuses dans
leur environnement le moins ils ont de
chances de s'infecter je pense que c'est
avoir une mémoire courte de penser qu'on
est au retour à la normale tout est pas
fini à 100% donc il faut toujours se
protéger oui
en ce qui concerne les fêtes de famille
nos experts sont unanimes on doit
refuser tous les invités qui voudraient
se présenter avec des symptômes viraux
il faudrait le dire à tout le monde si
on est malade on ne se présente pas dans
une fête de famille comme si on est
malade on porte le masque 40% de nos
spécialistes disent aussi qu'ils vont
fermer la porte à ceux qui n'ont pas
reçu de vaccin depuis six mois et le
tiers qu'ils vont demander à leurs
invités de passer un test covid avant le
réveillon on a aussi posé la même
question au grand public
on sent la bière
Radio-Canada Montréal